hey guys it's mkbhd and this is a 30  second tip quick tips videos are great  because it's quick for me to make the  video and it's quick for you because you  learn something really easily and really  quickly the only thing is i might have  to talk really really quickly so today's  tip is with tabs  and chrome a lot of people actually ask  about the pin tabs i have in the corner  of chrome when i do screencast with  stuff with a browser so without any  further ado let's go ahead and take a  look at that feature  right click pin tab watch it shrink  every time you open up chrome it will be  there  so there's a quick tip you're welcome  give it a thumbs up if this was helpful  so i'll talk to you guys in the next  video  get to the outro it's 30 seconds  you